familiar tunes a surprise character
reveal and a high-flying nod to the
games sonic the hedgehog 2 is blowing
away fans with its easter eggs here are
the best spoilers ahead
sonic 2 begins on the mushroom planet to
glimpse in the first movie where dr
eggman has been living out a solitary
castaway existence right down to his
conversations with inanimate objects my
grasp on sanity remains
absolute
[Music]
isn't that right agent stone the good
doctor receives a series of visitors
most significantly knuckles the echidna
the fact that knuckles first enters the
story on the mushroom planet is entirely
appropriate given that the locale is
clearly inspired by the sonic knuckles
level mushroom hill zone since sonic and
knuckles is the first game in which the
red echidna became a playable character
and since mushroom hill zone is the
first level of that game the stage can
easily be seen as knuckles debut his
green hill zone if you will this
introduction includes a couple of other
nods to the video games as well knuckles
being tricked into working for dr
robotnik is a common occurrence in the
games even eggman's little mushroom
machines could be seen as intentional
references to the sonic and knuckles
level which itself featured various
levers elevators and other gadgets made
of vines and mushrooms gross smelly
mushrooms
i hate mushrooms
in sonic 2 stone dr robotnik's loyal
assistant has opened up a coffee shop in
town the unassuming storefront actually
houses a range of robotnik's high-tech
gear and that's not the only secret it
holds mean being coffee co is the name
of the business a clear reference for
those who remember one of the most
unique sonic the hedgehog games ever
made released on the sega genesis in
1993 dr robotnik's mean beam machine is
a puzzle game set in the early sonic
universe though it's far from the
fastest sonic game available this
remained a well-remembered part of the
franchise's history even being brought
back for a surprise boss battle in
2017's sonic mania
sonic the hedgehog 2 features multiple
scenes of sonic demonstrating his love
of extreme sports namely skateboarding
and snowboarding he turns the house into
a skate park as soon as tom and maddie
leave for hawaii and he puts his skills
to the test later while escaping from dr
robotnik down a snowy mountain though
less of an easter egg and more of a
general reference sonic's predilection
for boarding of all types definitely
deserves a spot on this list in the
video games he often takes breaks from
his usual sprinting in favor of some
sort of extreme ride the action sequence
on the mountain in sonic 2 seems to fall
most directly from the ice cap zone
level in sonic the hedgehog 3 which
begins with an extended snowboarding
sequence
jim carrey's doctor robotnik has a
seemingly endless army of robots and
gadgets of all shapes and sizes and a
number of them are pulled directly from
the sonic the hedgehog games early on in
the movie after returning to earth he
acquires a small round hovercraft that
serves as his primary mode of
transportation a clear reference to the
famous eggmobile which the villain has
piloted some version of in nearly all of
the core sonic games robotnik's giant
final boss robot is also a clear call
back to the games albeit a slightly less
specific one than his flying pod the
evil doctor has constructed and piloted
all manner of mechanical behemoths
through the series occasionally
showcasing multiple massive robots in a
single game behold my floating
masterpiece to the egg carrier however
the one seen at the end of sonic the
hedgehog 2 appears most similar to the
final boss of sonic the hedgehog 2 the
game in addition to its design
robotnik's giant robot harkens back to
the series sega genesis days in another
fun way while figuring out how to pilot
the machine stone briefly shows off a
paper manual for it in the style of the
genesis's own instruction booklet right
down to the gridded black and grey
background
knuckle storyline and sonic the hedgehog
2 stays pretty loyal to the video games
and it includes a couple of smaller
easter eggs for dedicated fans the
general setup of the warrior echidna
tribe and the mission of guarding the
master emerald was changed a bit but
it's still very similar to the lore of
the games the emerald's hiding place is
also very similar to its home of angel
island in the games a more specifically
evocative moment in knuckles quest comes
at the very end of sonic 2. though the
master emerald is shattered into pieces
knuckles is able to locate every shard
and reassemble the jewel back into its
original form anyone who's played either
of the sonic adventure games should be
intimately familiar with this moment as
knuckles spends the entirety of both
searching for the pieces of the broken
master emerald the master emerald and
the island have been restored
perhaps more than anything video game
characters are remembered for their
special moves and there are a lot in the
sonic the hedgehog games with sonic
knuckles and tails all on the big screen
together in sonic 2 it should come as no
surprise that they each get to show off
some of their most famous techniques
from the games most of sonic's moves are
already seen in the first movie but it's
still fun to see them again he employs
the spin dash multiple times appears to
use variations of his boost moves from
games like sonic rush and sonic
unleashed and even seems to use his
homing attack a core piece of his kit
from the 3d sonic games in his battles
against knuckles and robotnik's robots
tails shows off his flying powers
throughout the film even carrying sonic
around in the air a couple times in a
manner incredibly similar to the games
uh did your butt just turn into a
helicopter tails also comes ready with a
backpack full of powerful gadgets from
laser blasters and anti-gravity pads to
scanners and translators and of course
knuckles shows off his own classic moves
in sonic 2 most notably his incredible
strength his ability to climb stone
walls with his knuckles and his gruff
attitude your society is full of soft
and undisciplined weaklings
if you're a long time sonic the hedgehog
fan expect to have your ears perk up a
lot over the course of sonic 2 for some
audio easter eggs tom's cellphone
ringtone is a variant of the green hill
zone theme for example
so help me thomas sorry sorry
sonic knuckles and tails all have game
appropriate sound effects associated
with their various moves and of course
sonic drops his internet famous line
one particularly fun thing about sonic 2
for fans of the games is that colleen
o'shaughnessy the voice actor who's
played tails for years in the video
games actually returns to voice him in
the movie
not too late given that sonic and
knuckles were both recast with big name
hollywood stars it's really nice to see
oshana c get some cinematic recognition
for her contributions to the franchise
she's fantastic as tails and sonic 2
just as she always is in the games
one of the big narrative twists in sonic
the hedgehog 2 comes in the middle of
the movie when it's revealed that
rachel's fiancee randall is actually an
agent of the guardian units of nations
or gun in fact the whole wedding turns
out to be a giant sting operation with
the goal of capturing sonic gun fills a
multi-purpose role in the franchise and
their representation in the movie is
pretty accurate to how they've been
portrayed in the past tom butler
reprises his commander walters role from
the first movie but this time he's
established as the leader of gunn given
how he's styled and his positioning the
story it seems that he's meant to revoke
the unnamed grizzled gun commander from
the video games
jim carrey's dr robotnik gets a lot
closer to the character's video game
look in sonic the hedgehog 2. the
ridiculous mustache bold head and
bd-eyed goggles are a big part of that
transformation
but robotnik also gets to rock some of
his classic clothes throughout the film
his main outfit is a red and black
jacket that evokes his look from the
more modern sonic games but there are
also some fun touches for fans of the
series time in the 90s in one scene
audiences also get a very quick glimpse
of a costume on a computer that looks
incredibly similar to the villain's old
skull outfit
sonic the hedgehog can't swim a trope
that sonic 2 plays on heavily early on
sonic and tom go fishing on a lake in
green hills where sonic emphasizes his
hatred of water and has an ability to
survive in it that moment sets up a far
more dangerous encounter later on in the
movie when sonic dives underwater to
save knuckles in the old games sonic
could run underwater for a certain
amount of time but it eventually went
out of air the only ways to re-up on
oxygen and keep going were to either
breach the surface or find a spot where
air bubbles would appear and float to
the surface the air bubbles released by
knuckles and consumed by sonic in the
movie are clearly meant as an homage to
this feature of the games for a sonic
player there is no more welcome sights
than an air bubble
in the final act of sonic the hedgehog 2
tails gets to fly a plane and not just
any plane a red bike plane meant to
evoke the one he frequently flies in the
video games sonic even perches on the
top wing of the plane as they fly into
battle against eggman's giant robot just
as he does repeatedly throughout the
series in later installments tails
modifies the plane with all kinds of
gadgets and gizmos including missile
launches different wing positions and
even the ability to transform into a
walking mech seuss he doesn't have much
time to tinker with the plane in sonic 2
but he at least adds on a little bit of
firepower for good measure it's also
worth noting that while the plane isn't
named in the movie the first scene in
which tales flies it features a massive
tornado because in the games the plane
is called the tornado that wasn't too
bad
the climax of sonic the hedgehog 2 sonic
finally unlocks the power of the seven
chaos emeralds and transforms into super
sonic the glowing golden form that lets
him fly around at even faster speeds and
blatantly rip off dragon ball z without
violating copyright it's a great moment
for fans of the games as most of them
end with similar battles between
supersonic and some giant enemy the
nature of supersonic has changed a bit
in the movie but not in any real major
ways in the games a heightened form
rapidly drains energy from sonic often
rings which doesn't happen in the movie
the film's supersonic design is spot on
however and the ensuing battle very much
reads like one of classic showdowns from
the games
of course sonic the hedgehog 2 wouldn't
be a modern adventure film without at
least one post-credits scene to set up
the next installment and this film
reveals a secret black ops site and an
initiative called project shadow
shadow it's you
the way in which shadow is introduced
also hints at some smaller details for
the franchise's future which many
viewers may miss
invoking the project shadow name
suggests that the movies are sticking
pretty close to the storyline of sonic
adventure 2 which was shadow's debut in
that game he's discovered by dr eggman
in the deaths of a gun research facility
called prison island where he's been
frozen for decades that could be the
same location glimpse in the sonic 2
post-credits scene of course it's
unlikely that the family-friendly sonic
films will ever dive too deep down
shadow's edgy side but there are a lot
of interesting possibilities
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]